[Music]
whoa what kind of Airship is that I've
never seen anything like it baby clayed
what is the president doing in our front
yard our entire world is in grave danger
I want you to come with me on an
expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when he went
missing but now you're all we got Mr
Clay I'm a huge fan thank you [ __ ] your
dad do you think you could Forge his
autograph
where in the world are we
Ethan you brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you
dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa what is
this place the cliffs are alive and the
waters dissolve the flesh off your bones
everything down here is trying to kill
us
[Music]
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday a
classic Jager claimed I was too
I'm loving this family reunion oh come
on we got a world to save
[Music]
I need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
see that coming
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
hey giant
you wanna see something cool
gracias the legend will never die
I have nine lives and how many times
have you died already
doesn't need a spotter watch
watch I can't always lands on his feet
watch
you are down to your last life Mama Luna
it's always on the lookout for a new lap
cat I have no laugh cat I am possible
not anymore
oh
[Music]
no
this is a person party pickles that's
your party so this is where dignity goes
to die
you don't look like a pickles well you
don't look like a cat full disclosure
I'm a therapy dog wanna roll my belly
make a talk
excuse me my darling we're looking for
the legendary [ __ ] boots have you
perhaps seen him what's up Puss and
Boots hey
it's me
oh
normally I have a soul it's like a whole
thing in it okay
get that cat Dead or Alive will be just
right bounty hunters
I need your help whenever I team up with
you things go wrong cool another member
of the team I'm pussy's therapy though
definitely not finally you need therapy
yeah
oh I have got to learn how to do that
life's flashing before your eyes pray
for Mercy from bursts and birds
what's up
[Music]
espresso
[Music]
I don't trust you trust me you
trust him look in those eyes are you
called that cute
stop you're gonna give yourself a hernia
it's a car tire foreign
I have no idea what that was
New York City did we just move here I
think we did you think Josh is gonna be
okay
this is my crocodile vile please take
good care of him
gosh time to wake up come on
he's not dangerous
he's just lonely like me hey you awake
yet you can't talk but you can sing at
the top of the world tonight
when no one ever
get out of here there's a crocodile in
the house
this could not be happy we have a
crocodile
that was totally awesome
the city must do something
do you realize how different things have
been since I met him
he changed everything for me
not just for me for YouTube
item we have to show people that they
don't have to be afraid
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
behold the king of the Coopers
foreign
[Applause]
do you yield
I do not
I finally found it now who's gonna stop
me
what is this place
do not touch that mushroom you'll die
oh I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine
come on Mario
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello Pops
Keepers and almost real boy
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
I want to be right here when you get
back
Pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody who wants to be a somebody
but I want to be real why on Earth would
you want to be real when you can be
famous
[Music]
okay we should have been home by now
he won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
be brave
truthful not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person panels
what's happening Jiminy looks like some
sort of fairy magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wish I could be
heart of that world
[Music]
oh
[Music]
I blamed bad luck for everything that's
gone wrong in my life
[Music]
you sure have bad luck Sam Greenfield
take that Universe cool
oh until
I found an actual Lucky Penny
something that could finally turn my
life around
[Music]
and what did I do
I flushed it down the toilet
your flushed my patties down the toilet
you just talked
wait I just need another Penny
[Music]
always with the obnoxiously long
password
[Music]
humans cannot be here where's here the
land of luck I'll leave as soon as you
give me another Lucky Penny you best
start blending in hello
Mighty leprechaun foil line well done
nature this is where good luck is born a
dragon she's the only creature that can
sniff out bad look there's bad luck here
too good luck on top bad luck on the
bottom the tiniest amount of bad luck
couldn't shut down our entire operation
just how unlucky are you
oh oh no
super duper unlucky you cause a disaster
the good luck connection has been
severed
I do you and everyone else to a life of
bad luck we need to fix this
good luck to us both
what about Jeff unstein yes
I have no words
[Music]
my name's pill
scratcher
probably and fluffy we're orphans we
live on the street and the Nobles sure
are gonna take care of us there you are
uh Eleanor hello and you're going to be
king Prince I've ruled over this Kingdom
since your father died and I've done
very well and you think that because
it's your birthday I'll just hand you
the throne never
I'm willing to help you out but in
exchange I want the treasure your father
left
it's up to you oh get away you beastly
things
so thought about my proposition you know
the crowd is ready I am a princess now
we have to make you human again we'll go
see that Sorceress in the cursed Forest
she'll help you princess could you maybe
hire us huh you can come with me and my
weapon will protect you princess
cockroach
let's do this
this is a rotten plant
I'm powerful and I intend to stay that
way
your highness printed we must act fast
or the prince will stay like this
forever
ready
what are you doing I've never seen this
guy before in my life
to prepare the antidote I'll need the
dung from a unicorn
oh Cockrell I dropped my poop I think I
did too
the original fairy tales are all the
same
the princess the hero but this story
is a little different
I am the amazing Maurice that cat can
talk well of course many of us can right
go go go
so what am I in your story you're not
handsome enough to be the love interest
then you're not funny enough for comic
relief
um right I'm off to get my adventure bag
let's go
I think I love her
looks like a town with opportunities
it's all quiet
there aren't any local rats here
it smells doesn't it smells like a a
mystery there has to be a clue that
would Advance the plots a world doesn't
have a plot things just happen
are you all right yeah I'm all right
because I landed on my head
so believe what we found
don't worry I can't always lands on its
feet
ah Maurice amazing Maurice you have to
fight it
[Music]
what you'll have to find out the rest
yourself the amazing Maurice it's really
not your average fairy tale important
safety tip don't need a dead rat that
just ate something that just say
something that made it dead
[Music]
[Music]
files you got a minute oh look
it's a long story is this the room you
grew up in uh it is but uh my my dorm
room is very adult right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
I missed you too okay so what are you
doing here I mean I I thought I'd never
see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
hi
I found it
bummer
what
is Spider-Man grounded
um
I mean I
[Music]
stop
[Music]
foreign
forever
[Music]
[Music]
there were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting happy 16th
birthday child
I have a gift from my favorite customers
Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her powers
foreign
[Music]
we must fly
Not freak out the eventful Maniac
obsessed with getting revenge on Salem
so very bad for Salem
we should get some salt why so it tastes
better when they eat us
[Music]
good
so far
[Music]
that's not Six Feet Under
oh I am a good zombie
[Music]
I guess
mommy let's not touch anything
I'm sorry you were saying
oh ah your face what happened to my face
your cursed
oh these curses get permanent if you
don't cure them soon
let's move
[Music]
mommy doesn't have that much time left
I want to see the world
[Music]
mummies are only Egyptian you're just a
sack of rancid bandages thanks I get
that a lot what did you do to the Mona
Lisa I fixed it
[Music]
Sophie I'm Tim for a young man
passionate about music there's no
greater place to be than Mozart's
[Music]
enough what what's this
there's a real magic in this Wars
[Music]
foreign
bring back my beloved daughter
you shouldn't take a risk if you can
figure out what it is
[Music]
to you
foreign
School library is a portal into Mozart's
beloved Masterpiece yes no
hey Lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference I'm
gonna be back in a couple days tops hey
Mom Dad has a work emergency so can you
come pick me up I love it when you call
me Mom let's throw a rager
what's happening
please don't
[Music]
be so tight it's some kind of superhero
layer your dad's a superhero what no my
dad can't handle hot wings
I have a crazy idea
step into the spotlight please don't
kill me
now that's fast
we got him
Whoever has this technology can do
anything
you gotta save my dad's attack before
they destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
dude that was too long that was way too
long
whoa whoa don't shoot I'm the IT guy I
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am I supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right yes
take time's over kids prepare for war
[Music]
hold it hold it these things are warm
yeah so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
I know the change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
if I learned anything from meeting
princess on a billboard is that
sometimes you just have to take a leap
let's start our new life
pretty soon this whole place will feel
like home you'll see
it's all part of the adventure that's
not an adventure that's a landfill a
land filled with Adventure
congratulations oh it's what they call a
fixer-upper yes once your peasants have
dug out the moat and added a turret and
a balcony from which you can sing I see
it now okay
Melvina Monroe I would have sold you
this house but I deal in slightly more
upscale
in andalasia the hardest part of life is
finding your happily ever after this
world's very different and this world is
not to your liking then you must change
it
[Music]
I wish
Jumping Jelly stick wait how am I
talking I wish
I wish for a fairy tale life and it's
all gone terribly wrong or terribly
right
last stroke of twelve nothing will be as
it was before
[Music]
Oh Giselle what have you done
foreign
[Music]
attention everyone
[Applause]
Santa has an announcement to make
[Music]
for the good of Christmas
the good of my family
hi Santa Claus
have decided to retire
d
we have a grease concert right
your interview and you become Santa
Claus yes can't wait to roll up this in
Brady's face
give us your best ho ho ho okay here we
go ho ho Omaha Omaha
see that I caught a little audible there
anyhow thanks so much I sing by the way
no Brady could say
[Music]
I do this
[Music]
dear Abigail
we regret to inform you that your great
uncle has passed away I did not know Mom
had a great uncle you are now the sole
heir to echoville Manor
wow
but we disappeared there many years ago
hasn't been lived in since
I'm sorry to have frightened you just
call me ghosted an evil ghost dragon
called Futo imprisoned me with a curse
we need to wait until the next full moon
the doorway to the chamber in the
basement will appear
please Elizabeth I need your help answer
the call I represent a powerful client
and we are looking for the instant
acquisition of echoville Manor the bank
now owns this property you're out of
here we can't let them take it your mom
wouldn't have let us just give up
without a fight I'm in welcome to the
skirt Squad and raise your spirits we're
here to repossess the property I want to
suck your blood
for the ultimate here it is the doorway
to the first challenge Supernatural
Adventure let me get this right everyone
has a device that has the answer to
every Quest
and they look at cat pictures
featuring David Henry as ghoster
come too far for you to stop us now
it's like you can actually touch them
enough with the poking
[Music]
ha foreign
[Music]